claude blanchemaison bonjour bonjour
heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france alors quelle
résonance politique dans le monde après
la désignation de cette présidence issue
de la communauté mapuche ici bas les
images sont très frappante et et cela
est finalement arrivé assez souvent au
chili puisque la dictature du général
pinochet a duré de 1973 à 1990 ce qui
est une dictature très très longue queue
ensuite il ya eu un retour à la
démocratie mais que au mois d'octobre
2002 19
des manifestations se sont déroulées
d'abord à santiago
à la suite d'une augmentation du ticket
de métro qui était sans doute la goutte
d'eau qui faisait déborder le vase en
réalité ce que les manifestants
reprochent au gouvernement et au système
c'est d'avoir installé un système
néolibéral où on a réduit
considérablement les dépenses publiques
d'éducation des dépenses publiques de
santé avec une très forte illégalité
puisque d'abord l'économie
l'économie du pays est fondé sur les
matières premières 50% des recettes
d'exportation viennent du cuivre il ya
beaucoup d'autres matières premières
c'est un pays relativement riches
l'un des plus riches d'amérique latine
avec une organisation économique
néolibéral mise en place de manière
forcée par pino s'est aidée par des
économistes à l'époque libéraux venus
tout droit de l'école de chicago
alors aujourd'hui devant ce blocage
finalement et devant les manifestations
qu'ils continuaient le président pinera
qui est un président de droite de la
droite libérale
c'est d'ailleurs aussi un milliardaire
quand hommes d'affaires et bien à
finalement accepté qu'il y est un
référendum dans lequel la population a
dit à une forte majorité qu'elle voulait
un changement de la constitution et
deuxième question qu'elle voulait que la
nouvelle constitution soit rédigée par
une assemblée citoyenne élu avec des
caractéristiques bien particulières
cette assemblée a été élu à la mi mai de
cette année elle comporte 155 personnes
strictement paritaire autant d'hommes
que de femmes et des sièges réservés aux
populations autochtones qui étaient là
avant l'arrivée des européens avant
l'arrivée des espagnols au xvième siècle
17 sièges sont réservés aux populations
autochtones
alors comment se fait-il que ce soit une
personnalité éminente parmi ces
autochtones puisqu'elle est professeur
d'université spécialiste de linguistique
elle enseigne l'anglais elle enseigne la
linguistique elle enseigne aussi sa
langue maternelle le mât koudougou et
elle a été élue probablement parce que
la gauche et la droite se neutralisent
et qu'en effet on a assisté rue gauche
il y à une alternance entre la gauche et
la droite
monsieur pinera ayant eu madame bachelot
comme successeur et puis ensuite il est
revenu au pouvoir
madame bachelet ayant été t il n'y a
perdu les ne pouvant pas se représenter
pardon une deuxième fois de façon
successive à son premier mandat
donc la c7
probablement que madame elissa langton
représentait en effet un point
d'équilibré
puisque ni la gauche ni à droite ne
pouvaient se départager
d'autant plus que les partis politiques
classiques ne représente que la moitié
de cette assemblée constituante
citoyenne la plupart des autres élus
viennent de la population civile des
avocats des professeurs des médecins et
représente un petit peu toutes les
catégories de la population y compris
d'ailleurs
on l'a noté des femmes des femmes qui
travaillent ou des femmes au foyer
donc c'est en effet très symbolique et
ceci va avoir beaucoup d'échos on a vu
les images de madame lancone après son
élection elle a fait un discours assez
fort et sera beaucoup de la percussion
en amérique latine et ailleurs dans le
monde alors justement claude à ce que ce
modèle l'assemblée constituante
peut-être reproduire dans d'autres pays
que le chili il va certainement servir
de référence mais la situation est
différente d'un pays à l'autre bien
entendu en amérique latine et ailleurs
je viens de dire que la situation est
particulière que le pays est
relativement développée mais que le
problème est surtout la structure
inégalitaire d'assaut une sous une
structure socio économique
particulièrement inégalitaire à peu près
autant qu'au brésil est effectivement là
la nouvelle constitution va avoir à
s'attaquer à ce problème
c'est très difficile dans une
constitution parce que il s'agit
d'établir une règle du jeu politique et
ensuite c'est les majorités au couloir
éventuellement en alternance qui vont
décider du détail de la politique à
suivre donc si le défi qui est lancé à
cette assemblée constituante
mais en effet une constituante paritaire
qui représente la société civile
c'est une grande innovation et
probablement que beaucoup de pays dans
le monde
nous voudrons y faire écho là où il ya
des manifestations de mécontentement
vis-à-vis du système vis-à-vis des
inégalités sociales
merci beaucoup que blanche maison pour
votre éclairage un édito diplo à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux en
attendant le prochain mardi prochain